so on April 23rd of 2013 The Associated
Press put out the following tweet on
Twitter
it said breaking news two explosions at
the White House and Barack Obama has
been injured this tweet was retweeted
four thousand times in less than five
minutes and it went viral thereafter now
this tweet wasn't real news put out by
The Associated Press in fact it was
false news or fake news that was
propagated by Syrian hackers that had
infiltrated the Associated Press Twitter
handle their purpose was to disrupt
society but they disrupted much more
because automated trading algorithms
immediately seized on the sentiment on
this tweet and began trading based on
the potential that the President of the
United States had been injured or killed
in this explosion and as they started
tweeting they immediately sent the stock
market crashing wiping out a hundred and
forty billion dollars in equity value in
a single day robert muller special
counsel prosecutor in the united states
issued indictments against three russian
companies and 13 russian individuals on
a conspiracy to defraud the United
States by meddling in the 2016
presidential election and what this
indictment tells as a story is the story
of the internet research agency the
shadowy arm of the Kremlin on social
media during the presidential election
alone the Internet agency's efforts
reached 126 million people on Facebook
in the United States issued 3 million
individual tweets and 43 hours worth of
YouTube content all of which was fake
misinformation designed to sow discord
in the u.s. presidential election
recent study by Oxford University showed
that in the recent Swedish elections
one-third of all of the information
spreading on social media about the
election was fake or misinformation in
addition these types of social media
misinformation campaigns can spread what
has been called genocide or propaganda
for a instance against the Rohingya in
Burma triggering mob killings in India
we studied fake news and began studying
it before it was a popular term and we
recently published the largest ever
longitudinal study of the spread of fake
news online on the cover of science in
March of this year we studied all of the
verified true and false news stories
that ever spread on Twitter from its
inception in 2006 to 2017 and when we
studied this information we studied
verified news stories that were verified
by six independent fact-checking
organizations so we knew which stories
were true and which stories were false
we can measure their diffusion the speed
of their diffusion the depth and breadth
of their diffusion how many people
become entangled in this information
cascade and so on and what we did in
this paper was we compared the spread of
true news to the spread of false news
and here's what we found we found that
false news diffused further faster
deeper and more broadly than the truth
in every category of information that we
studied sometimes by an order of
magnitude and in fact false political
news was the most viral it diffused
further faster deeper and more broadly
than any other type of false news when
we saw this we were at once worried but
also curious why why does false news
travel so much further faster deeper and
more broadly than the truth the first
hypothesis that we came up with was well
maybe people who spread false news have
more followers or follow more people or
tweet more often or maybe they're more
often verified users of Twitter with
more credibility or maybe they
been on Twitter longer so we checked
each one of these in turn and what we
found was exactly the opposite false
news spreaders had fewer followers
followed fewer people were less active
less often verified and had been on
Twitter for a shorter period of time
and yet false news was 70% more likely
to be retweeted than the truth
controlling for all of these and many
other factors so we had to come up with
other explanations and what we devised
what we called a novelty hypothesis so
if you read the literature it is well
known that human attention is drawn to
novelty things that are new in the
environment and if you read the
sociology literature you know that we
like to share novel information it makes
us seem like we have access to inside
information and we've gained in status
by spreading this kind of information so
what we did was we measured the novelty
of an incoming true or false
tweet compared to the corpus of what
that individual had seen in the sixty
days prior on Twitter but that wasn't
enough because we thought to ourselves
well maybe false news is more novel in
an information theoretic sense but maybe
people don't perceive it as more novel
so to understand people's perceptions of
false news we looked at the information
and the sentiment contained in the
replies to true and false tweets and
what we found was that across a bunch of
different measures of sentiment surprise
disgust fear sadness anticipation joy
and trust false news exhibited
significantly more surprise and disgust
in the replies to false tweets and true
news exhibited significantly more
anticipation joy and Trust in reply to
true tweets the surprise corroborates
our novelty hypothesis this is new and
surprising and so we're more likely to
share it at the same time there was
congressional testimony in front of both
houses of Congress
in the united states looking at the role
of bots in the spread of misinformation
so we looked at this - we used multiple
sophisticated bot detection algorithms
to find the bots in our data and to pull
them out so we pulled them out we put
them back in and we compared what
happens to our measurement and what we
found was that yes indeed bots were
accelerating the spread of false news
online but they were accelerating the
spread of true news at approximately the
same rate which means bots are not
responsible for the differential
diffusion of truth and falsity online we
can't abdicate that responsibility
because we humans are responsible for
that spread now everything that I have
told you so far unfortunately for all of
us is the good news the reason is
because it's about to get a whole lot
worse and two specific technologies are
going to make it worse we are going to
see the rise of a tremendous wave of
synthetic media fake video fake audio
that is very convincing to the human eye
and this will be powered by two
technologies the first of these is known
as generative adversarial Network this
is a machine learning model with two
networks a discriminator whose job it is
to determine whether something is true
or false and a generator whose job it is
to generate synthetic media so the
synthetic generator generates synthetic
video or audio and the discriminator
tries to tell is this real or is this
fake in fact it is the job of the
generator to maximize the likelihood
that it will fool the discriminator into
thinking the synthetic video and audio
that it is creating is actually true
imagine a machine in a Hyperloop trying
to get better and better at fooling us
this combined with a second technology
which is essentially the democratization
of artificial intelligence to the people
the ability for anyone
without any background in artificial
intelligence or machine learning to
deploy these kinds of algorithms to
generate synthetic media makes it
ultimately so much easier to create
videos the White House issued a false
doctored video of a journalist
interacting with an intern who was
trying to take his microphone
they removed frames from this video in
order to make his actions seem more
punchy and when videographers and stunt
men and women were interviewed about
this type of technique they said yes we
use this in the movies all the time to
make our punches and kicks look more
choppy and more aggressive they then put
out this video and partly used it as
justification to revoke Jim Acosta the
reporters Press Pass from the White
House and CNN had to sue to have that
press pass reinstated there are about
five different paths that I can think of
that we can follow to try and address
some of these very difficult problems
today each one of them has promised but
each one of them has its own challenges
the first one is labeling think about it
this way when you go to the grocery
store to buy food to consume it's
extensively labeled you know how many
calories it has how much fat it contains
and yet when we consume information we
have no labels whatsoever
what is contained in this information is
the source credible where is this
information gathered from we have none
of that information when we are
consuming information that is a
potential Avenue but it comes with its
challenges for instance who gets to
decide in society what's true and what's
false is it the government's is it
Facebook is it an independent consortium
of fact checkers and who's checking the
fact checkers another potential Avenue
is incentives we know that during the
u.s. presidential election there was a
wave of misinformation that came from
Macedonia that didn't have any political
motive but
instead had an economic motive and this
economic motive existed because false
news travels so much farther faster and
more deeply than the truth and you can
earn advertising dollars as you garner
eyeballs and attention with this type of
information but if we can depress the
spread of this information perhaps it
would reduce the economic incentive to
produce it at all in the first place
third we can think about regulation and
certainly we should think about this
option in the United States currently we
are exploring what might happen if
Facebook and others are regulated well
we should consider things like
regulating political speech labeling the
fact that it's political speech making
sure foreign actors can't fund political
speech it also has its own dangers for
instance Malaysia just instituted a six
year prison sentence for anyone found
spreading misinformation and in
authoritarian regimes these kinds of
policies can be used to suppress
minority opinions and to continue to
extend repression the fourth possible
option is transparency we want to know
how do Facebook's algorithms work how
does the data combined with the
algorithms to produce the outcomes that
we see we want them to open the kimono
and show us exactly the inner workings
of how Facebook is working and if we
want to know social medias effect on
society we need scientists researchers
and others to have access to this kind
of information but at the same time we
are asking Facebook to lock everything
down to keep all of the data secure so
Facebook and the other social media
platforms are facing what I call a
transparency paradox we are asking them
at the same time to be open and
transparent and simultaneously secure
this is a very difficult needle to
thread but they will need to thread this
needle if we are to achieve the promise
of social technologies while avoiding
their peril the final thing that we
could think about is
algorithms and machine learning
technology devised to root out and
understand fake news how it spreads and
to try and dampen its flow humans have
to be in the loop of this technology
because we can never escape that
underlying any technological solution or
approach is a fundamental ethical and
philosophical question about how do we
define truth and falsity to whom do we
give the power to define truth and
falsity and which opinions are
legitimate which type of speech should
be allowed and so on
technology is not a solution for that
ethics and philosophy is a solution for
that
nearly every theory of human
decision-making human cooperation and
human coordination has some sense of the
truth at its core but with the rise of
fake news the rise of fake video the
rise of fake audio we are teetering on
the brink of the end of reality where we
cannot tell what is real from what is
fake and that's potentially incredibly
dangerous we have to be vigilant in
defending the truth against
misinformation with our technologies
with our policies and perhaps most
importantly with our own individual
responsibilities decisions behaviors and
actions thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]